thanks for joining us America this is
the Dave Ramsey show open phones a
triple eight eight two five five two two
five let's go back and visit that last
call for just a minute because it's an
interesting exercise emotionally
spiritually financially and from
business principles standpoint okay
number one morally and ethically
speaking someone doesn't pay you you're
right to be angry I get angry I can't I
mean that's like somebody stealing from
you like someone putting a gun on you
and taking your wallet they stole your
time they stole your money a dadgum
thief not when you face that in business
now you've got a couple decisions one is
you let it eat you up which I have I
have done that in the past and or two is
you analyze what you can learn from it
you pay your stupid tax that's what I
call it when I lose money doing
something stupid and doing business with
somebody that's not going to pay me is
stupid so what did I do that allowed
them to come in and convinced me to give
my services without payment up front or
give my goods without payment up front
and how can I correct that business
practice and you know if I so I'm
looking for business trends and patterns
and so I'm trying to change my business
model so I get out of the collections
business I collect upfront cash on the
Barrelhead as they say I mean in the
retail world you pay upfront
business-to-business isn't you know few
things on your personal life you you you
can get and and then you know Bill
someone but most the time you know you
know you're going to pay upfront so look
at your business and think what you can
learn from getting ripped off and then
drop it and move on because you spend
all your energy chasing it not because
it's not right now
I'm not above going after someone
legally I'm not above taking them down
if they've got the money they're just
not paying me and I think I can collect
it and it's and I'm we did our job
properly you know yeah I'm gonna go
after them but I'm not going to spend a
whole
all pile of emotional energy going after
them it just becomes a matter of the
process of going after them but most the
time they're crooks or they're broke and
how did I allow a crook or a broke
person to take my services without being
without paying for them up front or my
goods without paying for them upfront I
need to change my business model I need
to learn from it well you just need to
learn to forgive yeah I mean it is about
forgiveness but you also need to
understand there's a difference in
forgiveness and reconciliation
forgiveness is I stuck my hand in a
fence that said don't put your hand in
here the dog bites and then I got bit by
the dog well I can forgive the dog
reconciliation is uh you know I stick my
hand in there again because I now trust
the dog know so you can forgive someone
and not be reconciled to them that's
perfectly consistent by the way Chris
from a Christian viewpoint I can forgive
you
but I mean if you're a thief and you
stole something from me I can forgive
you for that and I can move on and that
way the bitterness doesn't eat me alive
but I'm also not going to put myself in
a position you can steal from me again
that's reconciliation the only way I'm
going to be reconciled with you is if I
come to trust your character again and
see that this thing that you do is not
going to happen again there's a
difference in forgiveness and
reconciliation and that's true in
business as well with a business account
it's the exact same situation there so
you just kind of got to work that stuff
through and as you can probably tell
I've spent some time you know turning
these wheels crunching this situation
over in my mind and 25 years of doing
business because I used to would just
melt the helm and like that girl is
doing that's how I can tell I mean I
don't blame her I get it but its own it
becomes more about you and the damage
it's doing to you and your organization
then then this silly little crook that's
told 700 bucks from you and you know let
me just tell you crooks do not you know
well you have to stop them from doing it
again no not really oh really
you're not Superman you're not Jesus
just going about your business I mean if
you can follow a lot
or file a complaint something and you
know put put a black mark on them
somehow to keep them from somebody else
from getting ripped off that's fine it's
fine but this thing if I'm going to
pursue them to the ends of the earth
because it's not right they'll do it to
someone else I'm not really not really
it's really not your job something to
think through how you guys Rachel Cruz
here hope you are enjoying the Dave
Ramsey show and did you know that I have
my very own YouTube channel yes that's
right it's kind of better than the
dayroom 2 channel don't tell them I said
that I'm kidding I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you